is it anatomage to Top Gun absolutely
yeah
we might as well the cause is it's real
now isn't it Top Gun 2 is a real thing
now we're gonna yeah next year we're
going to play I think it's a good you
know daddy's a it's no monster you dude
you said that look you make that work no
honestly yeah you know I can't pay you a
compliment it's something I want to say
about job and for everybody on TV
throughout your career sob you're known
for action you're known for being the
man the go-to guy for so many different
genres and you've mastered them all and
I don't care if it's there's
pyrotechnics if it's if it's stunt work
if it's backflips or learning all these
new skills that you've developed over
your career the one thing you
consistently do that is magnificent is
maintain a character with an arc all the
way through a film and I learn from you
every single time I watch a movie and I
study your work Wow
[Applause]
soybean aphid thank you those are
beautiful words back and I asked you
thank you like a part and talking to you
I didn't mean it I'm good I'm sure he
meant it
I need men oh here we go
need procedures there we go oh man I
can't believe I got that
[Music]